the video has passed thank you ladies in
general if I wasn't a Christian and if I
didn't believe the things that I
believed I would be pro-choice I would
have gone to any length medically
overseen or not to end my pregnancy what
you ended was a unique genetic code that
had eye color hair color how tall would
be how much it would weigh its
personality when you put between event
abortion performed you eliminated all of
that that's a scientific fact is
Hollywood using its power to influence
your political views find out on this
episode of LED lives
[Music]
exposing darkness hello everyone you're
watching LED live the show we used the
light of Christ to expose darkness found
in media and our culture today and today
we're talking about Hollywood in
politics all right so I'm excited let's
get started okay so question for Scottie
you used to work in Hollywood in
California right I did yes
um did your productions ever bring you
out to the East Coast they did I worked
on a couple shows that I actually worked
in in New York for about a month or two
so I got a chance to experience the East
Coast and then in that sense nice do you
guys know which city on the East Coast
is considered the Hollywood of the south
[Music]
yes and that's because I mean Hollywood
and and Georgia as a state actually have
a pretty tight relationship
I mean Hollywood dumps billions of
dollars into Georgia's economy every
single year films and shows have been
produced such as to see the walking dead
you have Hunger Games
Black Panther currently has a box office
over 1.3 billion dollars and Tyler Perry
one of the most successful he is the
most successful african-american in film
history his production studio is based
in Atlanta and then we have Marvel
superhero franchise guardians of the
galaxy you have ant-man spider-man all
of these were made in Atlanta right now
George is in the dog house last week
Georgia's legislature approved the
living infants fairness and equality Act
also known as the House bill for 8:1
it's also called the heartbeat bill now
hearing all those terms what comes to
mind heartbeat bill abortion exactly
exactly so basically it abandons
abortions after a fetal heartbeat is
detected do you know how far into a
pregnancy you can hear the fetuses
heartbeat isn't it like a month it
starts to have a heartbeat or give or
take six
six weeks okay it's over a month right
okay
but before all of this was happening
jort it was legal for a woman enjoyed it
to abort her child 20 weeks into her
pregnancy that's about five months so
you don't get five months versus six
weeks it's a pretty big gap and it's
interesting the the controversy that's
going on not only in Georgia but
Hollywood as well so I want to pause
here though for a while and ask each of
you what your stance on abortion is as
an individual
I'll go first I believe in pro-life I
believe that that there is a miraculous
thing with that baby's life
is conceived if you look at some of the
scientific research that's been done on
when the sperm enters the egg there's
actually a flash of light that happens
right at that time and it is a to me
it's like it's a life at that point and
you know maybe there will be a struggle
maybe someone will have a harder
hardship but you know God can see some
of those children through and and they
can be a wonderful blessing to society
yeah I guess I'll go next
yeah I'm pro-life as well is preserve as
much life as possible you know and and
sometimes there's very sad situations
where that becomes very difficult you
know there are complications and the
mother's gonna die or the baby's gonna
die or both are gonna die but I just
believe that we should try to preserve
as much life as possible you know even
in those hard situations okay so
question when you say preserving as much
life the life of the mother of what
we're left with the child base of things
that's I mean that's I I don't know how
to answer that question I mean to me
it's a it's not my decision I don't know
what I would do in that case I mean
that's that's really challenging and so
for me I would just take this stance I'd
you know whatever you choose that's
between you and God and and I can't
answer that question you know whether
you choose that you know the the wife
that you love or the child that you love
that's that's on its way I mean how can
you choose that you know I don't know
how anybody can really choose that but
sometimes people have to make those
choices and that's really are you
rare and specific they are that you kind
of have to cross that bridge windows
those things come to basically make a
rule or a law off of that really kind of
obscure one thing is I think where we
get a lot of our ideas for abortion and
skewed exactly
I even from high school up till 2012 I
was saying I'm I probably wouldn't do it
but I think everybody has the right to
choose and then I saw a documentary
called 180 there's a 180 and it made a
parallel between like how Hitler kind of
brainwashed everybody into thinking well
certain races aren't even really
technically human so it's okay to
exterminate them that's what we're being
told about fetuses well they're not
really human yeah they're like a fish I
got the cells you can look at the you
can look at photographs from abortion
clinics and see that they have
fingernails features they're not a glob
of cells so I think there's a lot of
disinformation on this subject like
Scotty was saying they take it they take
a sort of a a rare case in an exact like
theory around that yes so whenever you
bring up abortion it's always life for
them another and all this but when you
look at the statistics that's 1% I'll
warn you right right the majority is
convenience and you know in the rare
case yeah in the rare case that the baby
or the mother's gonna die I think that
should be something that's case-by-case
the doctor makes a decision you don't
open some kind of drive-through abortion
clinic like come on in like why would
you make a whole thing for 1% yeah so
interesting that Mikey said at one point
you know he was pro-choice were you ever
approached choice at any point I was
actually I think in my earlier years I
would have definitely thought you know
hey there's there's cases and times when
that person is gonna have a harder life
if the child's brought into it but now
that I have children and I've
experienced that and I've seen that from
a different set of eyes I look at life
at a whole different way and
and I mean I definitely am pro-life at
this point but my earlier 20s I would
have been pro-choice I was too and
that's because I had a somebody in my
family who has gone through that and
somebody I really loved and and
identified with and so for me it was
hard for me to to put that condemnation
on that person so to speak in my own
mind and and say that well you know
that's that's a wrong thing to do
I didn't know I didn't want to place
them in that that you know box if you
will and I and I and I probably still
wouldn't you know because I'm not there
haven't been there but at some point you
know it shifted right it's interesting
I'm in my twenties and I'm if I had to
label myself I would say pro-choice so I
wonder hmm interest at a time I'm at
that stage of life if it'll change and
then I wonder too if the people that are
out there picketing are they more you
know I like if you just look at this
this photo here it seems like a bunch of
older ladies that are like hey I regret
this decision
I regret my abortion but then you see
some younger 20 year old right there
going oh keep it safe that's true all
the way across the board
yeah that's that's something to think
about it definitely I'll say also a very
controversial ad or something when I was
a woman wearing a t-shirt that was like
I had an abortion and she was like
celebrating at home I was just like I
just don't understand that I mean I
could see I was in this situation I had
to make a very tough decision I made it
but to like celebrate almost just seems
demented her okay so it really took time
for me to discuss it with friends and
really hash out this whole topic of
abortion but I came to this conclusion
right what is abortion abortion is
killing of a child or a fetus inside a
mother's womb it's killing so killing is
against the sixth commandment which is
thou shalt not kill and we know that
equals sin sin is a transgression of the
law
therefore me as a Christian should be
against abortion however that's my
religious belief so what I had to come
to terms with is
just like with God I should not force
obedience or before in the forcing of
obedience really when it comes to true
worship which involves the way we live
our lives it's all about choice right so
when when when it comes between a woman
and what she decides to do with her body
that really should be but a decision
made that she makes between her and God
and it shouldn't really have the
involvement of let's just say the
government we've heard all of your
positions and you mixed kind of your
religious beliefs with actual science
backings but overall is your position
more because of your faith or because of
your belief of civil rights whether it
is towards the mom or the fetus I would
definitely say I'm looking at this
through faith based eyes I mean my
relationship with God has really opened
up my my mind to a whole mess of other
things I'm I'm probably gonna come at it
from a faith-based point of view and
this maybe not quite in the exact
context this was written but in
Deuteronomy it talks about God and he's
saying I've put before you this day you
know life and death and he gives him the
answer he says choose life and not not
trying to take that out of context for
this situation but I have a tendency to
apply that you know towards other things
and say what does God want us to choose
I think he wants us to choose life when
you thinking of government there's
really two sides or politics rather you
have the pro-lifers which are more of
the far-right
evangelicals who are extremists in that
they really want to abolish abortion but
then you have the far left the the
Liberals who are all for choice to the
extent that we know in New York the
reproductive health act just passed for
people who don't know I think the bill
actually broads this this if I'm not
mistaken a health exception for
abortions up to as you just mentioned 24
weeks that's that's up to nine months of
pregnancy for age economic social
there's a list on the website do I have
that about
right so you can have an abortion for
any reason up until 24 weeks which is 6
months of pregnancy and then after 24
weeks so from 25 to 40 weeks so you know
the date of birth right you could have
an abortion for basically anything
because they quantify it as health of
the mother which can literally be
anything so right if I'm feeling
stressed that is impeding my health
right if I'm feeling anxious that's a
reason if my boyfriend ran out on me
certainly that's causing the emotional
distress so that's a reason so you can
now kill a baby through the date of
birth in this stage of music you can do
that right so you're looking at two
extremes so when I'm thinking about
government should there be absolutes in
government pro-life versus pro-choice so
that's why I said earlier if I had to
choose yeah would be pro-life but I
don't like the extremism found on both
sides and there really doesn't seem to
be any middle ground I I would have to
agree with you I I think that there is
an extreme outer edge there that's a
scary territory because even though they
may be utilizing their law or their
power in a certain way today you wait
till you get someone super evil in that
seat and all of a sudden you can see it
can go the other way real fast I think a
lot of our laws are written because some
crazy example happens you know somebody
goes into a church and shoots of a bunch
of people let's just change all the gun
laws then and and then now of a sudden
it's like you're probably not gonna take
the guns away from the criminals and
they're the only ones with the guns now
and you know does that solve anything so
III think that there is definitely a
boundary where we should allow our
government to make those choices but
then I also go you know as a pro-choice
ER with God then society really needs to
sit down and think about that and when
society gets to the place where it's
like you know not thinking on any sort
of like religious mindset then we either
have a choice to leave or
isolate yourself or you know I'm
thinking about wife and Jesus makes you
know several statements says I come that
they may have life and have it more
abundantly
you know in other words he wants to save
as many people as possible and just
where you draw those lines I mean Bible
says there's a wisdom and a multitude of
counselors and I'm glad that at least in
this country we are set up with some
checks and balances and a lot of people
that are hopefully doing their job and
looking at those those laws when they
make those decisions and saying this is
you know maybe the the parameters that
we should do it around and not trying to
go to extremes in one way or the other
it's unfortunate that those things
happen but to just say that I don't know
that it's the answer that we should just
not protect life okay it's interesting
you say that let's go back to the
government's involvement you know okay
this law is passed but what does it
accomplish okay less abortions and now
you have babies being born but at what
point does the government's involvement
stop because if you're gonna force
someone to have a child
wouldn't it be right to say you should
force I mean you should help them in the
development of the child and I'm talking
about health care education housing so
there's there's multiple scenarios there
and multiple options there's a lot of
people to have children and realize I'm
not capable of handling this and they
like everybody this is like every
panelist and and there are other options
where there are people you cannot have
children mmm I just can't like it's
biologically not possible for them to
have children but they have the means
and resources to take care of a child
and so this idea that it's like you know
again I think we're taking extreme
viewpoints and saying well if you're
forcing somebody in that situation it's
gonna be a strain on the system it
doesn't have to be you know there are
many options available out there where
people who would love to have a child
and care for that child and love for
that child and provide for their
education and provide for the health
care and all kinds of things so maybe we
as a society instead of looking at it
like well it's just gonna drain think of
it on the other side of the fence if we
have this
large group of unwanted children coming
into society what can we do with them
how can we then plug them in give them
you know a better situation how could we
make the system work for them to have a
better existence and and give them the
means I don't know maybe yeah I think
it's a little bit too challenging to
adopt I mean we know people that adopt
and it's cost
tons of money and all these funny hoops
everything I'm almost sympathizing with
the politicians because it's like maybe
we should make it easier but then you
make it easier and you got psychos
adopting children it's like wow there's
a lot to think about well there's a
difference between screening people and
expense upfront you know definitely we
should screen people just like you
should screen people who are getting
guns you know you don't want to just
hand over our gun to anybody but no need
to necessarily make it so expensive
exact people who are screened can can do
that and not burn a whole bunch of funds
that they could use in taking care of
the child I think a really good way to
to deal with a situation like this is
with information I appreciate these kind
of conversations I think we need to have
these kind of conversations just to
basically cut it off and everybody gets
up in arms well you know this is my side
of the thinking or this is my side of
the thinking this is how we as a society
come to grappling with these kind of
topics and come to some conclusion to it
and and we need to discuss them more you
know the countries that have a war on
drugs if you've ever seen any kind of
like documentation on how effective act
actually is that war on drugs there's
some countries that just say you know
what we're gonna embrace it and we are
going to instead of war against it we're
gonna we're gonna allow the drugs to
come into the country and we're gonna
just use information to teach people the
dangers of drugs and stuff and they are
actually much more effective than than
the countries that just say if you do
drugs we're gonna throw you in jail
so David chose to attack that problem
with information I think we can do the
same as well we can we can choose to
dump and flood our society with
information look if you have children or
you're sleeping around
you know that a child can come out of
that and you know we can give
information on what to do from that
point out and try to attack it from that
at the end of the day it seems like
you're getting that is can we force
people to make decisions or choices and
you know is that God's model it's
certainly not God's model but it seems
like any model that God set up whenever
you made that choice and he allowed you
to make it there's always been
consequences to that and for society to
say well we're not living a theocracy
anymore and there's consequences but you
know we're not going to help provide the
environment where those consequences can
can happen because people learn through
consequence you know it's like your
child if they lie to you and there's no
consequence
what's the idea they're gonna keep lying
to you you know so I think there should
be consequences that are a lot of have a
lot of eyes on it and a lot of people
come together and agree without
infringing on other people's rights
you know privacy safety but certainly
there should be consequences and at the
end of the day yeah you can make that
choice I'm all for people making
whatever choice but they need to think
through it and say what is the
consequence what is the long-term
situation gonna be if I make that choice
you know hopefully that's what we're
teaching our children to do is look
you're gonna go out into the world
you're gonna have choices to make if you
want to be lazy you can make that choice
but you're gonna struggle because you're
not gonna be able to get a very good job
being lazy you know okay well we're
talking about Hollywood in politics and
I say we're all trapped really really
interesting Alyssa Milano so she's an
actress in Hollywood and she's now
leading the charge in Hollywood against
this legislation we're talking about the
bill that was passed in Georgia about
abortion
she and 49 other actresses talking about
Amy Schumer Alec Baldwin Gabrielle Union
Sean Penn these are big names signed
this letter against the bill saying and
I'll read it quote as actors our work
often brings us
giorgia we've always found your state to
be populated with friendly and caring
people
however this dangerous and deeply flawed
bill
mimics many others which have already
been deemed unconstitutional listen
carefully as men who identify as small
government conservatives and now we're
seeing the extremes again we remind you
that the government is never bigger than
when it is inside a woman's body or in
her doctor's office I want you to pay
attention to the language in this last
piece we want to stay in Georgia we want
to continue to support the wonderful
people businesses and communities we
have come to love in the Peach State but
we will not do so silently and we will
do everything in our power to move our
industry to a safer State for a woman if
HB 481 which is the bill becomes law now
notice the language she's she's saying
that if this bill becomes law they will
be forced to move to a safer state now
my question is what about this bill is
unsafe yeah going back to talking about
how the government is really trying to
protect society and the people living in
it when you think about it just looking
at the science no the longer a woman is
pregnant but actually progresses through
the trimesters if she decides to go
through with the procedure of abortion
she is more at risk than early on so
saying the cutoff time is six weeks is
actually helping the woman wouldn't you
agree yeah I think it's interesting how
Hollywood tries to really muscle their
weight around you know not even
discussing the the implications of that
it's just there like if you don't do
what we say then we're just going to you
know pull out somewhere else how many of
them actually go through with this stuff
how many celebrities are like if Trump
gets elected I'm moving out of the
country and they're still here I mean
it's still the best country I mean
that's true they they're gonna they're
gonna throw their popularity around as a
as a commodity but so are they really
gonna say from here on like oh this
blockbuster movie you're gonna get
millions of dollars I've become the
Georgia
no we're not gonna go see them yeah I
think this happens a lot in Georgia
actually because Georgia probably has a
lot of people that are more you know
conservatively minded maybe and so these
bills make their way you know up through
the chain and then when it gets to the
top then these bigger industries take
notice
I mean Delta's in Georgia Coca Cola's
and Georgia you got some big businesses
in Georgia and if they're trying to
please the loudest voice maybe not even
you know the right voice or the voice of
the representative people but the
loudest voice then they're gonna you
know take their their concerns to the
people at the top and use the almighty
dollar - yes weigh their votes
I think the celebrity is gonna take the
hit harder than Georgia itself and all
that they have going for them I mean
they're gonna be the one missing out on
the opportunity to act in a sort of
movie or whatever okay
well in summary this letter which was
posted on Twitter surprise surprise
threatened a boycott if the bill becomes
state law but actors are not the only
ones against the bill we have the
Writers Guild of America East and West
which are label unions that represent TV
and film writers so they also took to
Twitter and posted a letter in
opposition to Georgia's abortion ban
legislation calling this band
quote a blatant attack on every woman's
right to control her own body in their
post they said this draconian anti
choice law would discourage people in
our industry from working in Georgia and
could harm the state's vibrant film and
television industry now they continue in
the letter saying it is entirely
possible that many of those in our
industry will either want to leave the
state or decide not to bring productions
here now let's think of the magnitude of
this we have three to five thousand jobs
scheduled to be opened in 2021 you have
billions of dollars that Hollywood is
dumping into Georgia's economy it's
thriving off of what Hollywood is doing
and now Hollywood is saying we're going
to with the draw from you if you put
this bill into law now do you think what
do you think about this situation where
it is literally stepping outside of the
bounds of just producing entertainment
and to using its power to to sway
government's decision-making I think art
is meant to affect the viewer they're in
the business of affecting society in
fact a lot of our ideals are shaped
because of these productions that
they're putting out there the the
dialogue that's put into movies the way
that those characters interact with each
other the storyline between the people
that you know they're making movies
about that are okay with abortion and
stuff those are having an impact in
society so it doesn't it doesn't shock
me that they're using their influence to
you know get what they want in in
politics I mean they're in the business
of shaping people's minds ultimately I
think you're you're saying you know well
I'm okay with the fact that if I was
that child and that mother I would not
exist you know you have to be okay with
that decision the child doesn't get any
say you know everybody's making the
decision for them and it's like you have
all these people that are that it's
already had a hard enough time to get
where it's at and then before it's even
born
it's got like all these people that are
like against that child you know coming
to full tournament and being born and
it's like I don't know just place
yourself in that child's shoes you know
everybody's making the decisions for you
you don't get to choose you know it's a
it's really a miracle that it's gotten
this far and it's in its lifespan and
and it could be snuffed out so quickly
okay well let's let's go back to Scott I
remember you talking about information
you know how information should be put
out there to kind of do the problem and
people should be able to choose and also
the dialogue in Hollywood can really
influence a lot of people it's
interesting because a movie was released
last week March 29 called unplanned so
it's a Christian film by the same
producer
of God's not dead it's a movie about
Abby Johnson who becomes the youngest
clinic director in history of Planned
Parenthood then a life changing changing
experience turns her into an
anti-abortion activist happy Johnson is
in the other room here our first order
of business is to present Planned
Parenthood's Employee of the Year award
Abby Johnson this is Abby
she's our newest volunteer escort Abby
this is Cheryl Alessandra I'd be the
youngest director in Planned Parenthood
history you'll actually be in charge of
the abortions at your clinic I have a
chance to make a real difference the
only thing that's changed is you Abby
you even hear yourself talk right now
about these procedures these are little
babies I'm not going to apologize for
doing a job that helps women in crisis
they're still part of me that isn't sure
but the one thing that all experts agree
on is that at this stage the fetus can't
feel anything sorry to bother you but
they need an extra person in the back
room are you free
I saw it was like twisting and fighting
for its life we commend the souls of
these hundreds of children
and Lord we pray to end abortion I
really appreciate what you've done for
us I'll not forget it 22 even covered
[Music]
rough day at the office your dad and me
you are our baby from the moment of
conception we are paying you to be a
perfect instrument of corporate policy
we are an abortion provider I can't be
part of this anymore everything that
they've told us is a lie don't
underestimate the repercussions of this
you got to be careful let me tell you
what's gonna happen if you bail through
that door
[Music]
congratulations you can make an enemy of
one of the most powerful organizations
on the planet
this film is is a really honest look as
to what happens in abortion clinics so
it's an attempt to make the idea of
abortion more tangible so someone can
make a more educated decision but I want
to talk about Hollywood's response to
this film because it's not really what
do you think pro-lifers were really
shocked and confused when the motion
picture associative Association of
America MPAA gave this movie an r-rating
part of the issue has been that this
movie got an R rating which a lot of
people thought was ironic that young
women who in most states could go have
an abortion without their parents
involvement couldn't go watch the movie
hmm another interesting they don't want
kids to see it basically mm-hmm were you
anticipating that were you surprised
what's your response to that
Hollywood is about politics it's not
about making movies it said it's about
propaganda with Hollywood and you know
we are pro-life guys in a pro-choice
town and so we are not like and the
movie is not gonna be like so to expect
that they would give us a fair reading
okay not gonna happen so we kind of knew
that we wished for the best understood
that the worst could possibly happen and
that when we got the are didn't surprise
us I live in a country where my daughter
can go out at 13 she can get an abortion
without parental consent
but she can't go to see this movie okay
wait wait so this into my mind for a
second they gave it an r-rating why oh
yeah we're gonna get into that because
of the violence so not only did they
give it a our rating Hollywood blocked
advertisements so you wouldn't see this
on TV except if you're watching what is
it Christian Broadcasting Network you
see it on there but not on the regular
Channel well another interesting thing
is they had a Twitter page this movie
had a Twitter page with thousands of
followers and it got shut down and
reopened a new one yes
dan this is just one of the most recent
examples of censorship bias on Twitter
what's your thoughts well I mean the
Twitter is consistently the worst of all
the social media outlets there is no
pretense so I mean you know this is not
the treatment that liberals receive
Planned Parenthood move or abortion
movies don't get shut down their
accounts don't get shut down on their
opening weekend you don't have people
who try to follow the account and it
automatically unfollowed you yeah I mean
there's a huge uproar on Twitter and
Twitter's response is always the
immunity oh yeah okay and they move on
if imagine the media outrage if this
happened to some sort of left-wing
account it's simply the way it is
Twitter is no way shape or form a
neutral platform the Conservatives see
you know that tells me they own the
machine right they're blocking the
information you say something gags you
say something against what they believe
then they're gonna just cut it off and
and that that channel is not gonna be
able to to be open to this type so I
believe in freedom of speech and these
people try to claim that's what they
believe and we won't accept as we want a
voice with we want representation but
yet we don't get to have that side we're
always silent pro-choice we want you to
be able to choose anything but choose
something that's different than us data
that's crazy
so um what's quite comical about this
r-rating you guys remember the movie
venom yeah you know that was rated pg-13
of course right it's crazy because he's
totally demonically possessed anyway
that's that's that's way less than
killing babies was there any violence in
that they were killing people but you
didn't see any actual blood it was black
it was real cartooning something like
that every Marvel movie pretty much
every Marvel movie in comparison in
terms of contents to this movie is worse
yet almost all their movies is rated
pg-13 while this one is rated R let's
look at some examples
last year it contains instances of
torture and impale a black panther very
popular movie contains stabbings
gunfights and UFC type fistfights came
out last year contains more than 70
course words and I say course instead of
curse because you know there's different
words that are not considered really
curse words but you wouldn't want your
like seven-year-old son action film live
free or die hard about 100 course words
in Titanic remember 1997 movie had
cursed a wait were you born then curse
words sexuality and nudity all of these
phones are rated pg-13 PG I knew it was
and we haven't even started on broadcast
television regular shows Abby Johnson in
response to the MPAA rating of unplanned
what you know his rated R she released
an open letter addressed to parents
making it clear that this film contained
no profanity no nudity no sex assuring
them that the film's tone runs a full
range of laughter and tears and a
detailed she details the specific scenes
that basically triggered this rating in
particular so I'm gonna share it with
you two and then yes that's it out of
our two-hour movie Wow so this is
another instance where you don't need to
see the movie in order to make an
educated decision whether you should
watch it or not so this is what she says
one scene shows what I saw on the
ultrasound screen when I assisted in the
abortion procedure that convinced me of
the humanity of the unborn you will see
what I saw a baby on an ultrasound
screen in black-and-white 2d you will
see the abortion instrument which looks
like a big straw in real life and like a
dark line on the ultrasound introduced
onto the screen you will see the baby
struggle against it you will see the
baby first slowly then quickly disappear
into the instrument as it does what it
is
to do Johnson stresses the footage is
not of an actual abortion and it was
necessary to keep it in the film because
it tells the truth of what our culture
keeps trying to insist is a right and a
freedom the second scene recreates my
awful experience with the abortion pill
including some blood in real life I
hemorrhaged so badly I thought I was
going to die Johnson writes adding that
the film captures her experience without
being gratuitous or gory Johnson
concludes that she cannot make the
decision for parents themselves but
shares that her own twelve-year-old
daughter will see it and other friends
who have seen it plan to do the same our
children are of the generation who is
being lost to abortion this is personal
for them too she writes yes it's a movie
about abortion but even more so it's a
movie about the truth of forgiveness
repentance and redemption because that
is what the story of my life is really
about
we were just looking up the statistics
on the age of people of woman who go
through abortions and you see that it's
15 to 19 that's 10% and over 20% is ages
20 to 24 these are the people who should
be exposed to this information and know
exactly what's going on in the clinics
any comments on this yeah I've heard a
lot about I think it might be the
company or the organization choices but
they go around with a truck and they're
fully licensed and everything and they
just want to give women ultrasounds
before they have a an abortion that's
all they want to do we just want to show
you the baby and they get run off all
the time by the abortion clinic people
like we don't want you here and so why
aren't they wanting the women to see the
baby and it's really ironic that this
got an r-rating probably by people who
are pro-choice but we okay so what we
say is okay we don't want to see
on-screen why would you stand for
something that you don't even want to
see I think it's also a testament to the
power that media has because they would
not react in this type of way if it
wasn't going to influence and obviously
put it in our rating he's gonna put that
decision-making
that is able to view this early enough
to like before there's an actual
abortion or a problem they'll make a
decision I think those decisions are
made at 13 14 15 so if they put those
numbers you know that you can't go see
this until this high I mean it really
minimizes that I think that's a
testament to how powerful media can be I
mean it can influence because a huge
discrepancy here you know because we're
saying this is rated R for two scenes
and you're basically putting it on the
same level as something like Deadpool
it's rated R you know which Deadpool by
the way had a curse word literally I
think every minute yeah or half a minute
out of the thing there was a hundred and
something curse words in the entire
production weight and sexuality right
and and and yeah and and not to mention
the the gore and violence in it you know
so you know there's a huge discrepancy
and then and you take some of these
pg-13 films and we say well this is not
as bad as that I mean it's fine for your
kid to see something like that but right
I mean well despite Hollywood's efforts
to block this from the public view
unplan unplanned as of now has a box
office of seven million dollars so the
word is getting out there people are
going to see it on traverse it can be a
good thing sometimes exactly exactly
yeah if they go you know they won't let
them play it here or they're not
promoting it in any way shape or form in
the public so only Christian radio
stations and things you know that should
make a lot of people curious yeah I'm
curious I didn't know like what did they
say in this thing
well don't really go Hollywood knows me
to my next question as Christians in
regards to this biographical film
because it is about her life she'll be
watching should we encourage other
people to watch it you know I think I
think there is a place for film I really
do and I think in such an important
conversation piece like this there's
there's a lot of different varieties of
how we can share information we can
share information with a book we can
share information with a documentary
some people maybe aren't going to go and
read a book
or be exposed to you know digging around
on the Internet
but they will sit down and watch a film
so I think God is in the business of
saving people and III think he's using
whatever means he can and these guys are
using the tools that they have at their
hands they've they've clearly gotten
very good at it and you know this is
potentially a film that that I will
actually sit down and watch yeah I think
that they are thinking of the same way
we do what we do it's a information war
we're trying to it's like a spiritual
war we're trying to show you the reasons
why you should watch certain things so I
think they're doing the same thing well
if people are gonna watch movies anyway
let's see them something that's good and
informative yeah you know III think for
any of our listeners out there if you
guys know of anybody that is you know in
this age range where they potentially
have gotten pregnant accidentally and
are really contemplating this I mean I
think everything begins with prayer sit
down ask God what is it that you want me
to do and show me the information
convict my heart and those things I
believe will lead you God will lead you
he's not gonna ignore you to the right
pieces of information so that you can
make a good and well educated choice but
you know if you if you give that choice
to God God what do you want me to do I
guarantee you he will keep knocking on
your heart that little small voice will
be loud and clear in your mind and
you know I think he'll help you out I'm
gonna say at the end of the day I'm with
Mikey here you know if you're gonna say
that you're pro-choice does that spill
into other parts of your life I mean
shouldn't you be pro-choice that people
see something like this you know
information you know let people make
their own decision you don't have to
shut something down necessarily because
you don't agree with it you know do I do
I believe there are certain things we
shouldn't watch or do absolutely but you
know at the end of the day you know you
have to let people make those decisions
for good or for bad we'll do our best to
influence people you know for the right
way and I might say yeah you know
there's this you shouldn't watch it
Deadpool and here's the reasons why but
at the end of the day it's your choice
and you know I'm not gonna necessarily
go out and pick it at Deadpool and you
know and try to shut down their twitter
account and all that and you know it's
like you have to choose you're the one
that's accountable to god so I say if
you're pro-choice you know let people
choose don't thank you guys so much for
discussing this topic with me and thank
you for watching LED live we really
appreciate your support don't forget to
Like comment and definitely subscribe
share this video with as many people as
possible to get the word out that LED
live is here or something
bye
[Music]